ad first NBA Cup champions how's that
sound to you sounds great um first to do
it first team to win it uh we know it's
not the real thing but you know we keep
taking steps in the right direction um
obviously Indiana is a great basketball
Club they shown what they can do all
season um but I think just our energy
our effort to start the game our Focus
um was it was off the charts tonight but
the first to do it we'll take
they wouldn't go away just what were you
guys doing defensively particularly
against halberton to just keep holding
them off he's making it tough for him I
mean you know he got four different
Defenders on him uh he had DLo he had
Austin uh he had cam he had V uh and we
it's it's a it's a team effort to guard
him I mean he's he's a hell of a player
like I said we seen what he did against
Milwaukee what he been doing all
year we just got to make a tough for him
you know it's all five guarding him you
know making other guys make shots
getting the ball out of his hands
because he can beat the team by himself
our guys called it bully ball you guys
had more than 80 points in the paint how
how were you able to do that what was
the key to that just attack in the
basket um you know we got some of there
at least shot blockers in foul trouble
and then we just felt like the the paint
was open for us to attack and finish and
it was just about get into the basket
you know we didn't want to settle we
wanted to put pressure on them at the
rim and we was able to do that as good
as you were on the offensive end the 20
rebounds the locked shots just what was
your defensive mindset from the opening
tip AB help my team whatever it takes
like I said I know they a great
offensive ball Club they can score it
will it's my job as the anchor of the
defense to lead the team on that end of
the floor and that's what I want to do
um you know talking to my team making
sure that they it's okay to for them to
pressure the ball no I got their back
now I know the money's nice but we've
heard that LeBron had you guys kind of
locked in from the beginning of this
tournament what what did this tournament
this Championship mean to him to you to
all all of you
guys you know you know obviously you
know he's he's a leader at the team
along with myself and you know we want
to be the first to get this I mean like
I said you know the money is obviously
the money um but we're seeing how we're
growing I mean you know we were able to
go 4 and0 and pool play and then we got
to Vegas and it was like we we here we
might as well go win it all um you know
playoff style of basketball brand
basketball we was able to do that but
you know for him to come out how he
played on Thursday night just to lead
the crowd lead the charge um and then
for all of us to lock in knowing that
this is the final the final step to win
it all let's lock in and get it done
thanks congratulations thank
you